my name is Michiko Lombino and I'm the
chef of Moreno the calzone is folded
Itza that is stuffed what makes a good
calzone is a calzone that is not too wet
not so seen something cheesy what it
allows you to do stuffing that needs to
stay moist was on top of a pizza it
would dry very quickly roast and it
would not exactly be the same friend of
mine told me about his grandfather
recipe for calzone it was a very well
put together little recipe a nice
stuffing a little different and I
thought it was just a perfect so I say
ok let's just put it on the menu and see
how people like it
Rocco is his name so I called it Rocky's
calzone
which has nothing to do with Rocky
Balboa known as a guy from Brooklyn so
the way we do our cars on here at
motorino is first we make the filling
it's a sweet sausage and a spicy sausage
they both get the renders in the pot and
once we have the sausage fully cooked
we just drain the fat cows will return
the the crumbles cook sausage into the
pot and then we will add eggs and we'll
cook it on medium heat until the eggs of
scramble so essentially what you have is
eggs and sausage scramble
that's when you add a good amount of
pecorino which is the the highest note
flavor is some parsley for the collar
steer it in that's your feeling we use
the same dough as the pizza the most
important ingredient is timing by the
time your fermentation or you time
you're resting you can do car servicing
wheels you open the pizza and then you
will place the stuffing on one side we
fold your design on top we seal the edge
with the finger and then on top we put a
little bit of garlic more pecorino and
olive oil just before it goes
- give it I did a bit of a crisp to the
top and a little bit of a roasted garlic
flakes on top of it we used the regular
Neapolitan oven so good fire and I said
that's because oh I grew up in Belgium
and I ate a lot of Italian food
especially growing up in an Italian
family and I thought that pizza was
something that was just perfect for me
really the good eats area don't write
the had good chance to learn
successfully pretty much anywhere in
Italy you go to the pizzeria that you
like and you go over and over because it
works for you and that's what my aim is
I don't aim to be the best in the world
I just aim to be a very good material
that works that works
[Music]